the politicians can pretend it's
something else but Donald Trump calls it
radical Islamic terrorists right now I
don't want to talk politics I don't want
to talk about who you should vote for or
whose campaign ads are more effective
what I do want to talk about is how
campaign ads brainwash you using
hundred-year-old filmmaking techniques
the technique is called the montage and
it was one of the first visual
storytelling techniques in film to start
let's watch the most famous montage of
all time
[Music]
[Applause]
so here's the question do we ever
actually see Marion crane get stabbed
the closest contact the knife makes is
right here that's it
but with montage with a series of images
moving rapidly across the screen you can
convince a viewer they see her stabbed
repeatedly
the scene consists of quick shots of the
knife Marion's body and Marion
struggling and screaming when seeing
those images all at once we associate
the images with each other and create a
story in our brains of what we saw
essentially we got brainwashed now the
third way is what one might call pure
cinematics the Assembly of of film and
how it can be changed to create a
different idea here's another montage in
Citizen Kane in 1941 it tells the story
of Susan Cain being forced to perform
across the country under the pressure of
her husband Charles Cain
here's a more contemporary montage with
two people shooting up heroin we didn't
actually see anyone do the drug but the
Assembly of the images told the story
for us now we have a close-up they we
show what he sees let's assume he saw a
woman holding a baby in her arms now we
cut back to his reaction to what he sees
and he smiles now what is he is a
character there's a kind limit its
sympathetic so let's see how campaign
ads do it the world a president has to
grapple with sometimes you can't even
imagine that's the job
and she's the one who's proven she can
get it done securing a massive reduction
in nuclear weapon in Hillary Clinton's
new world campaign ad we cut from the
White House and it's long white pillars
to Hillary Clinton walking in front of
more long white pillars to her walking
off a plane to her talking with Vladimir
Putin
now these editors have thousands and
thousands of pictures of Hillary Clinton
to choose from for this commercial it is
no coincidence that they chose an image
of the White House and then three clips
of common activities and locations we
associate with presidents the walking by
the White House pillars the leaving Air
Force One the talking with other world
leaders all reinforced with the use of
the phrase that's the job these editors
are using a montage of images to make us
imagine Hillary Clinton as president
when we see her working hard in these
familiar spaces we imagine her filling
those same shoes and see her as a
president in a positive familiar way but
montaging campaign ads can also go from
positive to threatening now let's take
the middle piece of film away the woman
with the child but leave his two pieces
of film as they were now we'll put in a
piece of film of a girl in a bikini
he looks girl in a bikini
he smiles what is he now the dirty old
man he's no longer the bin
gentleman who loves babies that's that's
what Phil can do not just abroad but
here at home with the clear and present
threat of radical Islamic terrorism on
the March we must secure our borders but
Washington continues to fail us with
groups like the gang of eight that
support amnesty and allows sanctuary
cities
this video shows radical terrorists and
illegal immigrants in a menacing dark
green tint followed by the Capitol in
front of a thunderstorm followed by
Marco Rubio this montage along with the
tint and grainy found footage look
cinematically associates Marco Rubio
with something Americans fear the most
terrorism the montage manipulates the
audience to see Rubio at his policies as
terrorist friendly what immediately
follows is Ted Cruz in bright saturated
light speaking in front of a large crowd
serving as a metaphorical savior to
Marco Rubio in the first half of the
commercial America needs Ted Cruz the
one proven conservative for president a
Donald Trump ad uses a similar technique
by fading out from Hillary Clinton and
Barack Obama to to Muslim looking people
and an ambulance carrying an injured
person in the background the politicians
can pretend it's something else but
Donald Trump calls
Islamic terrorists these montages are
carefully assembled to associate Clinton
and Obama with terrorism with the right
images in the right order you can create
whatever emotional response you want I
want to make it clear that this video is
supposed to be nonpartisan Republican
ideology allows for more brutal campaign
ads because they want to show Democrats
are soft on terrorism Democrats to be
just as brutal could also portray
Republicans as vicious war mongers think
about it I would bomb the here we see a
montage generalizing the Republican
candidates keeping them in low
saturation low quality footage and
physically shrinking them in small
aspect ratios and of course Hillary's
clips are bright and take up the whole
screen eight who can stop them Hillary
Clinton I wouldn't be surprised if
Hillary campaigners made a montage of
wounded soldiers like Nixon did in one
campaign out in 1968 never has so much
military economic and diplomatic power
being used so and effectively as in
Vietnam the point is that the Assembly
of images is extremely powerful
everybody does it and it's not just
limited to movies this form of cinematic
brainwashing happens all the time not
only in campaign ads but also other
commercials beer commercials don't sell
beer they sell an idea and that idea is
conveyed through a montage of people
smiling being social and having fun
so know that more goes into campaign ads
than you might have thought and remember
not to just vote for the candidate who's
editor put images together the best my
name is Jack Nugent and I approve this
message
thanks for watching see if it is a cool
slightly trans to fall just a bit of a
break from the norm
just a little swapping the break the
monotony of all that